ich glaube jetzt nur noch auf die kälte
rein gegen und nicht anders ich ja sage
ich ungern also da wenn ich mir über
diese werte jetzt hier anschaue heute
nacht wieder weiter unter minus 10 grad
im berliner raum das ist fast schon mit
hannover - 15 -16
kassel - 13 aber wenn du noch mal auf
play drücken das geht zum teil noch
weiter herunter an einigen stellen - 17
-18 grad morgens das was aber mal weiter
laufen tagsüber dann minus sieben grad
das ist mal bis mittwochfrüh grad laufen
so vielleicht jetzt mal ein stopp so
dann siehst du hier nicht erschrecken
minus 20 grad waren es da gerade für ein
stück zurück da hat die technik genau
mittwochmorgen das also ich kann das
auch kassel - 18 -20 grad extreme kälte
und werden dass er eben gesagt bitte
keinen draußen alleine lassen
das sind werte die sind für uns sehr
sehr selten
das ist wirklich auch gefährlich auch
für menschen die vor erkrankungen haben
also jetzt nicht einfach raus und und
längere zeit draußen überschätzt man
vielleicht seine kräfte vorsichtig sein
das ist eine ungewöhnliche situation für
deutschland seit vielen jahren nicht
mehr so eine kälte
wir müssen damit jetzt umgehen die
nächsten tage
ich sag mal ganz vorsichtig ein bis zwei
wochen mindestens haben wir diese eisige
kälte hier in deutschland also richtige
frost das ist eine richtige peitsche
jetzt reden wir ganz oft davon die
temperatur die gefühlte temperatur wo
ist denn da jetzt der unterschied und
ist das wirklich so ein so ein krasser
unterschied sich x ja also es ist so
dass sobald der wind über die haut
streicht cloud der die wärme weg das
heißt der körper versucht ja unser
körper versucht ihr die temperatur auf
37 grad irgendwo zu halten jetzt stell
dir vor der wind der nimmt mit über der
haut dann einfach die wärme schneller
weg als wenn es windstill wäre und das
macht sich dann schon deutlich bemerkbar
allerdings nimmt der wind jetzt ein
bisschen ab und in den nächten haben wir
das problem dass wir überall schnee
jetzt haben und dann verliert diese
hatte schneedecke die luft unglaublich
schnell die wärme in den weltraum und
gerade teilweise klaren himmel
und deswegen haben wir so sensationelle
werte - 18 -20 grad
und ich verrate das ist jetzt noch nicht
offiziell weil man muss immer vorsichtig
bei etwas längerfristigen prognosen aber
ich finde es wichtig dass schon mal zu
sagen
nächste woche könnte es noch markanter
wert
ich habe da teilweise in
computermodellen minus 25 grad und nur
noch kälter werte gesehen also irgendwie
irgendwie haben wir die haben wir diese
eisschrank temperaturen jetzt hier
gebucht und wir müssen damit umgehen und
wir nähern uns sage ich mal von dem
gemessenen den gefühlten temperaturen
also wir müssen längere zeit mit diesem
extremen frost umgehen mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren